[Music]
I think when I look back over my life
I've lived quite positive life
Tina Turner had an ageless spirit and it
was a joy to spend time with you
the singer was almost 70 when she
invited E.T to this private Rock concert
in 2008 during our three and a half hour
visit she never slowed down how do you
stay so hip I mean you are so down with
it
you are are you kidding me right now oh
those girls
I know what you're telling me you're
saying to me you're 70 years old I know
that's what you want to say isn't it but
you're done with it next year I am I'm
70 years old I just have energy it this
I do nothing I've never done drugs
a little wine champagne on off days but
not even now at off days but uh no I
just don't need this is I was born with
this
what's your problems
I've got fans way back from you I
Cantina days so they're going to be the
17 year olds and down so we we arranged
an intermission for them take a little
break and go and fan and have some water
Tina's career started with her first
husband in the Ike and Tina Turner
review in the 60s years later Tina
revealed that Ike's abuse nearly cost
her her life it played out on the big
screen in the movie about Tina's life
1993's What's Love Got to Do With It
starring Angela Bassett I'm teen
my husband and I just had a
lot if I am supposed to open at the
Academy tonight
I have 36 Cents on a mobile cop
but if you would give me a room
s where I will pay you back it was
always a black eye a broken nose a
busted lip I was totally finished with
the life and it was just a matter of
cleaning just of leaving Tina left Ike
she was broke and turned to cleaning
friends homes they didn't like this all
Tina how can you I was pleased I was
happy I needed to earn my way
at 44 she released her biggest solo hit
and her career skyrocketed selling more
than 200 million records it was 1977
when I left I Turner
my life is
progressed progressively climbed and
became better and better and better I
have no reason to think about this man
not even on stage the arrangements of
mine the musicians play as I want them
to play my my stage performances are as
I want them to be now not as how I would
have wanted I have gone on with my new
life
and it's wonderful
[Music]
that new life included a pre-game Super
Bowl performance in 2000 E.T was there
at rehearsal on the field and at her
side on game day how did it go out there
how wonderful Boy you know you made me
forget there's a football game today
well you can't forget that E.T
interviewed Tina 33 times over the
decades the first in 1981. it's
fantastic to still be here and to do it
and while her look evolved Tina's
passion for rock and roll never wavered
I just feel like we'll finally my style
has caught up with itself because I was
obviously ahead of my own time
[Music]
in 2018 Tina launched her 50th
anniversary tour it would be her ninth
solo concert tour
[Music]
when it's easy to sing of course it's
fun but the hard part is weaving and
something different yet still giving
them the songs that they want to hear
and that kind of performance
[Music]
in 2013 she married German music
executive Irwin Bach 17 years her Junior
I found him quite attractive and I made
it known to him and I wasn't thinking
about age
the couple lived in Switzerland and Tina
never looked back
being happy
that's that's what I am I'm a happy
person these days when the show goes
away what's the next chapter to be
written for Tina Turner oh that's
interesting I think I'll probably have
to be a hundred
[Laughter]
someone said once she's got a fire in
her stomach and it'll never go out I
start to think about that it's probably
he's probably right I just have energy I
was born with this
[Music]